we look up to the greatest esport
players because they can pull up plays
we could never even imagine most of the
times we're the ones best playing and
losing well they're the ones getting
burning collats and pulling off 1v5 ace
clutches but sometimes pros do things
that are a little less than optimal
unlike us though even their stupidest
plays are still top tier
because when the best players go stupid
they can still do things you never
thought would be possible but before we
get into the video i just gotta let you
guys know that we've teamed up with our
friends over at predator gaming to give
you a holiday gift guide you might have
hurt some of our other hosts already but
here's daniel rosen giving you what he
wants for his holiday season
[Music]
all right folks you heard liz we've
teamed up with our friends over at
predator gaming to bring you a little
holiday gift guide you've probably
already heard from some of my friends
who host other shows already but
basically we're gonna tell you what we
want this holiday season and maybe we
can give you some ideas of what to ask
for for yourself so let's get started
the pandemic is finally ending and i'm
really excited to finally get to travel
again and one of the things i'm most
excited about traveling to is fighting
game tournaments that's why one of the
things i want most this holiday season
is the snack box micro look i have a ton
of fight sticks actually i have so many
that i don't know where to put all of
them but one more can't hurt right and
at least this one is so small that it
looks like it fits really easily into a
suitcase look traveling with bulky
stakes was one of the only annoying
parts about going to fighting game
tournaments so getting a stick that
looks easy to pack sounds awesome and
not to be greedy but while we're talking
about traveling i'd really like a way to
play games on the go and i think i know
exactly what i'm looking for look we all
want a steam deck i know i'm not being
original but this thing looks like it
rules getting to play my entire steam
library anywhere means i might finally
work my way through my giant stupid
backlog anyway you can probably tell i'm
all about traveling again which means
i'm gonna need a new laptop luckily our
friends over at predator gaming have
just what i'm looking for with the
predator triton 300se like i said i'm
looking for a sleek and powerful laptop
that i can stick in my suitcase since
i'm trying to spend as little time at
home as possible next year so a thin
easy to carry laptop with an intel 11th
gen h-series core i7 processor and 9
hours of battery life that's good for
work and gaming is exactly what i'm
looking for this holiday season i'd
recommend checking it out at your local
best buy all right that's it for me back
to the top 10.
[Music]
kicking off our list is an outplay so
staggeringly simple you could only come
from the goats it could be really rough
for simple to actually get through this
he's gonna throw the awp oh my god
simple what is happening back in the
semi-finals of esl new york 2016 when
team liquid was facing off against navi
ukrainian superstar simple found himself
in a tense 1v1 against former teammate
nitro since simple heard the bomb being
planted under window he rushed to peak
so nitro wouldn't have a chance to
retreat nitro heard the approach of
course but simple anticipated that
problem is simple didn't have a flash so
he threw the next best thing his op
could be really rough or simple to
actually get through this he's gonna
throw the awp oh my
god war is happening to this day we
aren't sure if nitro was actually phased
by simple so-called 4750
flashbang or if he just lost the
gunfight what you've basically done to
everyone playing counter-strike for the
next three weeks is everyone is going to
be throwing orps over walls now thanks
for that
it was just like fake you know he's like
what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah
throwing her up before a round deciding
duel isn't exactly a brilliant play but
when simple does it it well
it just works
taking the number nine spot on our list
is the time ee sama bought rapier on
slark
it's the upper bracket final of the
shanghai manger in 2016. secret were
down two racks as the team liquid and
their cheese adoring carry eternal envy
was doing everything he could to keep
his squad alive seeing the the secret
wanted there i may lose roshan and as
you said this is going to be massive for
liquid
mv okay that's a freebie that's a
freebie and it's a big one 50 seconds no
touch they can go on this oh karoki
getting jumped forward but he's there
coming in as well the crosstalk down the
side and he's going to go down that's
the really head let's see if he gets
there back he doesn't usually don't
reply on super super man fighters
probably getting the envy understand he
gets tired
after executing a crucial team wipe
eternal envy had racked up enough gold
to buy his next big game-winning item
which everyone thought was going to be a
bissell blade since it synergized with
slark's single target tear down instead
he went a different route for those who
don't know divine rapier is an
egregiously expensive all or nothing
gamble it boosts your right clicks by
whopping 300 damage but if you die while
holding it your enemy can pick it up off
your corpse it's also terrible on slark
because his base attack speed is low
until he's stolen enough agility with
essence shift all in all it was an
absurdly risky pickup but somehow he
pulled it off
[Applause]
look at the emotions there in the booth
there's not quite a secret i don't think
a lot of people would have believed this
coming into this tournament all hail ee
sama
it's time for some off meta picks
because at number eight we have laxing's
roaming off-site echo relaxing bringing
out some new stuff here on the echo the
aggro roaming echo not something that
you see very often not the first time
we've seen it either to be fair but
certainly the first time i've seen it in
this style all's fair in love and war
and bullet holes definitely fit that
description facing off against team bds
in the group stage of the 2026
invitational laxing knew he was going to
have to get extra rowdy to bring down
shaco bds superstar but no one expected
him to bust out echo for the job
of all the operators laxing is all the
way in narnia with the crazy line in the
wall of billiards oh my god he gets him
relaxing oh you want to talk about rat
that is ridiculous echo is mostly used
to anchor sights in siege not roam
around the map and look for picks but
laxing wasn't just using echoes acog to
abuse insane lineups he was executing
jiggle peaks with one of his yokai
drones to scout for potential runouts
he's like i i think he's in strip and
now laxing is staying over here and he's
jiggling a yokai out of the door to see
if he can kill anybody on a run out this
is the most aggressive echo play this
isn't the kind of pick that should pan
out at the literal world championships
but it led to reciprocity winning the
round and the map not too shabby
at number seven it's mango proving
sometimes these smartest plays are also
the dumbest i think you do need that
edge garden i think you should take me
seriously because look at the scoreboard
right now yeah i got numbers
joe did he just walk up slowly and down
smash he did during his winter's
quarters matchup against tax at big
house 4 melee legend mango was looking
for ways to not only throw his opponent
off his game but toss him a little bit
of shade as well
there's been a conversation between
these two players for a long time okay
where
manga was even making fun of him on the
mic yesterday saying every conversation
i ever have with hacks he complains
about falcon and i tell him all the time
that i can beat him with my falcon and
now it's finally happening yeah i
witnessed the money match at evo 2014
and
mango bodied my dude
but with hacks at set point mango was
staring down the barrel of a brutal
upset which is when he did this i think
you do need that edge garden i think you
should take me seriously because look at
the scoreboard right now yeah i got
numbers on them
joe did he just walk up slowly
and down smash he did now those who know
mango know he's cerebral unpredictable
and plays by feel but as we all know
there is a thin line between genius and
insanity what mango did was quite
literally drop his defenses and walk to
his death but somehow it worked and it
tilted hacks off of the face of the
earth now it goes for a safe edge guard
he's trying to keep this stock he's not
not trying to overcommit too much you're
gonna get the back here no
oh
[Music]
so that's
i'm not sure how that happened the top
comment on vg bootcamp's video put it
best sometimes being bad is the best
thing you can do
taking the sixth spot on our list is no
tidehunter's perennially p-brained level
one roshawn bait
oh my games now on the penis the swedes
they pull something out of the bag and
feed is gonna go down as well
just seconds into game two of the
dreamhack winter 2012 grand finals no
tidehunter executed one of the most
sophisticated yet absolutely idiotic
tricks dota has ever seen admiral
bulldog given a freebie and here we go
game is on
the bait is lame now a level 1 roshan is
not unheard of in dota but it's risky no
tidehunter went a step further though
they did the only thing dumber than
doing level 1 roshan
pretending to do a level 1 roshan see
when a hero dies to roche the other team
gets a notification
but no tidehunter knew this we had
admiral bulldog sacrifice himself to
roche on purpose to trick eg into
thinking they were trying to roche but
they weren't
and it is it's actually a trap because
they came to check for it now the stun
it goes out
they're gonna bring it down oh my games
now on the penis the swedes they pull
something out of the bag and feeders
gonna go down as well
oh no tide hunter
this is one of those plays that's so
stupid it manages to wrap back around to
being brilliant
taking the halfway spot on our list is
proof that daigo truly is the drunken
master of street fighter i said he might
try something as soon as he's in
winner's bracket but i didn't see that
coming
in his grand final matchup against
gamerbee at dreamhack winter 2013 [ __ ]
umehara one of the greatest street
fighter legends to ever live was looking
to send a message about how the game was
about to go
so in the very first round he does
this
great reaction there you go
[Music]
the first two uppercuts were reasonable
anti-airs but the rest they were just
cruel and tilting some might call this
genius but in reality daigo was opening
himself up completely
he was spamming dp as an oaky option
because he knew it was going to work
that's not something you do unless
you're ready to get destroyed as james
chen points out courtesy of red bull
without a meter required focus cancel
everything after you reach this point
is vulnerable
if the real player showed you kids
anticipating an approach but the
opponent instead simply
stands there
the opponent gets all this time to
prepare the best and flashiest way to
destroy his life bar
there's a good reason daigo is the goat
for the fourth spot on our list we're
rolling back the years to messiah's
legendarily stupid tf outplay uh what
the ninjas are using
was china's twisted fate god and his
signature trick was an absurd bait used
tf's old to teleport into the enemy team
they then used zhonya's hourglass to
initiate
here's shot caller esports explaining
why this trick worked
the play would draw out several key
abilities from the opposing team and
would bait them into sub-optimal
situations it's incredible that spending
two long cooldowns make your enemy
believe the literal oldest trick in the
book actually worked but this guy was a
legend for a reason
coming in at number three is a plot
strat that terrorized the overwatch
league the bumper
bumpers
from the back the shatter comes down
good night huxol follows up get skomsu
this guy has been doing this for ages
and still people don't look both ways
bumper is best known for his insanely
aggro reinhardt play and his signature
move is the bumper shatter where he
maneuvers the giant slow hero to flank
the enemy and then hits them with a
massive shatter ultimate from behind you
never think these kinds of tricks would
work in pro play but during the
vancouver titan stage 1 week 1 face-off
against shanghai dragons bumper hit a
shatter so painfully silver
that it sent his opponents for a loop
set bumpers
this guy has been doing this for ages
and still people don't look both ways
now you might be thinking isn't this a
pretty low elo play like pros can't fall
for this [ __ ] more than once right
well
you'd be wrong okay bumper's looking
through all the free charge kill way to
go he's hiding around the shutter oh boy
here we go what is he doing he does it
right now goodbye goodnight elephant
mystic not on this push says bumper
kills two with a charge
huddling together at the number two spot
on our list is an oldie but a goodie
the fanatic death brush epic uh epic
gaming know that they are ready to play
in this one and nope they're still
standing there who wants next yeah who
wants to come in the most nice let's go
let's go again we're ready back when
westerners were actually good at league
fanatic were feared for pioneering a
very particular tactic
standing in a brush
as five and well
waiting see if they can set up around
young generation here they go from the
sidewalks to jump in looking for pallet
that's fresh still very tanky though is
they not fanatic bag young generation
perhaps want the re-engaged now as ren
goes to the front line a child from jazz
is a five-man child the knock-up [ __ ]
still alive and he's gonna pound away on
caps wren dead two dead from young
generation fanatic able to collapse able
to get the fight they wanted for those
of you who don't know an enemy unit is
only visible within a brush and the
brush has been warded or walked into
realizing that fnatic figured out that
if you just stand as five in a brush
some idiot might walk into your trap
and you can see the call is to back away
the soraka is benefiting fnatic fairly
heavily here because what's happening is
the poke land soraka heals it up and
rocket it's not an all-in fight yet oh
that would blow through it did and now
the depth charge is coming yard takes a
lot so it's flashing forward across
multiple lineups fnatic has busted out
this strat plenty of times over the
years it's a brainless strap that
so-called pros shouldn't fall for and
yet the literal best teams in the world
keep falling for this [ __ ] and they can
go back to playing around baron and
luke's force fight or doing what they
did before five men grouped towards the
enemy jungle death broth
the classic here is balance pulled back
in it's going to go down flinch for a
little while longer but cat finally
collects it
taking the number one spot on our list
is the single stupidest cs go play to
ever win a major
it's coldzera's jumping off
it's jumping
what is it going on right now how does
he do this down 9-15 in the semi-finals
of the columbus major luminosity needed
a huge play to get back into the game
with liquid on match point and rushing
through apps all coldzera could rely on
was a hail mary play to save his team
yeah there's a lot of pressure on him
he's gotta hit these shots we saw
fallenness in this spot before the same
spot but with much more utility to work
with coldzera was basically on his own
against all five members of liquid the
first shot was relatively easy
but the rest seemed impossible cole
didn't have time to hop into barrels or
van so he did the most brain dead thing
any cs go player could do in the moment
jump
click
and pray
here he comes once again the first base
is a trend he's to hit the ground
there's cold oh
wow that's jumping double for code what
is it going on right now how does he do
this this is a million to one play your
accuracy takes a hit when jumping so
that's why no one does it but cold one
for the play it's so impossible that
youtuber dinosaur leaf had to run the
odds to illustrate just how ludicrously
lucky it actually was
and coldzera defied the game mechanics
by jumping and taking a shot killing not
only one of his opponents but two with
one bullet
[Music]
the play broke liquid their mental was
in the toilet and luminosity won that
map the series and eventually the entire
major it's probably the craziest major
play of all time and definitely the
dumbest remember what the great one once
said you miss 100 of the shots you don't
take
even the stupid ones
well folks that's our list if you think
we missed an idiotic play that actually
worked let us know down in the comment
section below take care and i'll see you
in the next one
okay i got him
oh
where was